als nächstes werden sich die
Abgeordneten mit dem Wohngeld
beschäftigen das sogenannte Wohngeld
plus Gesetze wurde hier von der
Bundesregierung und auch von den
Fraktionen eingereicht und auch die
Linksfraktion hat hier vier Anträge
eingereicht indem man es zum Beispiel um
Kündigungen geht oder auch um mieten
bzw um
CO2-Preise inwieweit diese auf die
Mieterin und Mieter
rüber gereicht werden können wir schauen
jetzt erst einmal auf das Wohngeld plus
Gesetz das ist eines der
Neuerungen die es jetzt geben soll auch
als Komponente des entlastungspakets der
Bundesregierung da gab es ja der Bund
länderrunde wo viel im Vorfeld schon im
Oktober ja schon gerungen wurde wie hier
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger entlastet
werden konnten im Oktober konnte man
sich nicht einigen und jetzt hat man
sich vor einer Woche dann unter anderem
auf das deutschland-ticket für 49 Euro
geeinigt die gaspreisbremse und eben
auch um die große wohngeldreform die nun
kommen soll und aus der SPD wird nun
Brian Nicoles als erstes erläutern was
die Koalitionsfraktionen davor haben
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren das Bürgergeld haben
wir beschlossen jetzt beschließen wir
die wohngeldreform Bürgergeld und
Wohngeld gehen Hand in Hand zusammen ist
das ein sozialpolitischer Meilenstein
Menschen deren kleines Einkommen nicht
reicht um die hohen Wohnkosten aus
eigener Kraft zu stemmen die nichts
dafür können dass die Wohnkosten immer
weiter steigen diese Menschen werden mit
dem Wohngeld plus kräftig und
zielgerecht entlastet und das ganz
gleich ob Sie zur Miete oder im Eigentum
wohnen
damit schaffen wir eine wirksame
Entlastung bis in die Mittelschicht
hinein
vor vier Wochen war hier die erste
Lesung der wohngeldreform heute wollen
wir das Gesetz beschließen so schnell
bringen wir diese Reform auf dem Weg und
das ist auch notwendig liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen das zeigt es macht einen
Unterschied wer mit wem dieses Land
regiert ein gewaltigen Unterschied
[Applaus]
in der Öffentlichkeit wurde viel über
Bürokratie und Personalmangel gesprochen
es ist zentral dass die Umsetzung vor
Ort funktioniert viele Menschen stellen
neue Anträge und setzen dich zum ersten
Mal mit dem Wohngeld auseinander deshalb
ist es klar dass es gerade am Anfang
etwas länger dauern wird die Reform ist
eine Herkulesaufgabe für die Kommunen
das stellen wir nicht in Frage aber was
ist denn die Alternative Liebe Union
diese Reform ist alternativlos die
Menschen in Deutschland brauchen diese
wohngeldreform jetzt und nicht später
die Menschen haben diese wohngeldreform
verdient
diese gemeinsam zu meistern und
umzusetzen ist die Aufgabe die Länder
werden ganz sicher alle Möglichkeiten
nutzen um die Kommunen dabei zu
unterstützen
wir haben die Hinweise genutzt und
Verbesserung aufgenommen konkret
bedeutet das eine Bagatellgrenze von 50
Euro ein Bewilligungszeitraum von 24
Monaten eine Konkretisierung der
vorläufigen Zahlung damit es eben eine
Verwaltungsvereinfachung ist alle diese
Punkte haben wir noch zusätzlich in den
Gesetzesentwurf geschrieben
an dieser Stelle danke ich meinen
Kolleginnen von der FDP und den Grünen
für die gemeinsame Arbeit
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen viele
müssen mehr als die Hälfte ihres
monatlichen Einkommens fürs Wohnen
ausgeben viele davon wohnen in schlecht
sanierten Gebäuden und bezahlen sehr
viel Geld für die Nebenkosten dazu
kommen die hohen Energiepreise und die
Inflation all das macht das Wohnen noch
teurer genau deshalb genau für dieser
Menschen stärken wir das Wohngeld
noch mal zur Erinnerung und ganz kurz
mehr Haushalte mehr Menschen mehr
Wohngeld
klimakomponente drin
heizkostenkomponente drin damit helfen
wir dem Menschen die es brauchen ganz
konkret egal ob sie zur Miete oder im
Eigentum wohnen hohe Wohnkosten dürfen
keine Armutsfalle sein unser Ziel ist
ganz klar bezahlbarer Wohnraum für alle
und das sorgen wir ein Beitrag mit
diesem Gesetz
und vielleicht ein letztes Wort noch zum
Thema was wir noch alles tun müssen um
bezahlbaren Wohnraum zu schaffen uns ist
doch vollkommen klar dass das ein
wesentlicher Baustein ist aber nicht der
alleinige wir wollen im Mietrecht wie in
anderen Komponenten durch das Bauen von
neuen Wohnung durch Sanierung dafür
sorgen dass der Druck vom Wohnungsmarkt
genommen wird und ich setze darauf dass
wir auch bald zum Thema Mietrecht aus
dem Justizministerium einige Vorschläge
zu bekommen werden herzlichen Dank
Brian Nicoles war das für die
SPD-Fraktion und hat hier die Debatte
zum Wohngeld plus Gesetz
begonnen direkt auf ihn Antworten wird
nun an den König aus der Unionsfraktion
gerne persönlich gesagt der Weg zur
Hölle ist mit guten Vorsätzen geflastert
sie mögen gute Vorsätze gehabt haben
aber der Weg zu einem guten Gesetz
besteht eben aus weit mehr als
vollmundigen Ankündigung das Resultat
ihrer Anstrengung ist bitter für die
betroffenen Menschen denn wann das erste
Wohngeld in 2023 gezahlt wird weiß
aktuell niemand laut Experten wird das
antragsvolumen auf das 4-5-fache
explodieren dem sind weder ihr Timing
noch ihr Gesetz gewachsen der Deutsche
Städtetag geht davon aus dass das
Personal in den wohngeldstellen
verdoppelt wenn nicht sogar verdreifacht
werden muss um den zusätzlichen
Arbeitsaufwand zu bewältigen je nach
Größe der Kommune werden 10 bis 100 neue
Mitarbeiter gebraucht der Arbeitsmarkt
ist leer die kommunalen kassenklamm das
wird nicht funktionieren
und das wird vor allen Dingen nicht zum
ersten ersten 2023 funktionieren bis zum
ersten ersten 2023 werden auch nur mit
viel Glück die it-fachverfahren in den
Ländern angepasst sein und dann ist noch
kein neuer Mitarbeiter geschult der
Deutsche Städtetag rechnet deshalb damit
dass in den ersten Wochen bis Monaten
des Jahres 2023 gar keine ich wiederhole
überhaupt keine nicht ein einziger
Wohngeldantrag wird beschieden werden
können auch nicht Folgeanträge von denen
die schon immer auf Wohngeld angewiesen
waren zum Januar wird außerdem wohl
niemand eine Vorschusszahlung erhalten
in den Ämtern werden spätestens dann
verzweifelte Bürger auf eine heilungs
überforderte Verwaltung treffen als
Bundesregierung somit Menschen die ein
Recht auf Unterstützung haben umzugehen
ist ein Skandal
selbst die von allen geforderte
Bagatellgrenze für Rückforderungen haben
sie erst vorgestern ins Gesetz
aufgenommen man fragt sich warum erst
jetzt begreifen sie erst jetzt was
dieses Gesetz mit all seinen
Unklarheiten und was ihre großspurigen
Ankündigungen bewirken werden darüber
dass die klimakomponente mangels
Anrechnung des gebäudezustandes einfach
mit der Gießkanne verteiltes Extrageld
ist und das ist an einer transparenten
Systematik der mietstufen mangelt mag
ich gar nicht erst reden bereits im März
hatte unsere Fraktion die Reform des
wohngelds beantragt dass sie sich damit
mehr als acht Monate Zeit gelassen haben
ist alleine ihnen zuzurechnen und von
ihnen zu verantworten wenn gute Vorsätze
nicht mit guter Politik unterlegt werden
und hier haben sie eindeutig
Nachholbedarf dann stimmt das Sprichwort
der Weg zur Hölle ist mit guten
Vorsätzen gepflastert sie produzieren
beim Wohngeld gerade ein Desaster mit
Ansage
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ein
kleiner Hinweis derzeit tagt parallel
das wissen sie natürlich der
Haushaltsausschuss in der
Bereinigungssitzung für den
Bundeshaushalt 2023 und die
Bundesministerin für Wohnen
Stadtentwicklung und Bauwesen steht
gerade den Kolleginnen und Kollegen dort
im Haushaltsausschuss Rede und Antwort
das nur zur Forderung dass die
Ministerin anwesend ist damit alle
wissen woran wir hier sind wir fahren in
der Debatte fort das Wort hat die
Kollegin Hanna Steinmüller für die
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sind in
einer Energiekrise für viele Menschen
mit kleinen Einkommen bedeutet das große
Herausforderungen je länger der Monat
geht für die Rentnerinnen und Rentner
mit den niedrigen Bezügen für die
Alleinerziehende mit dem Teilzeitjob für
die Menschen mit einer großen Familie
und kleinem Einkommen für all die ist es
unsere Aufgabe in dieser Energiekrise
Sicherheit zu bieten
das wohngeldplus-gesetz ist ein Baustein
dafür dank der Reform erhalten mehr
Menschen mehr Geld anders als bisher
werden ihm nicht mehr nur die Kaltmieten
herangezogen sondern die warmmieten es
gibt eine heizkostenkomponente und eine
klimakomponente die dies steigenden
Energiekosten und die energetischen
Sanierung berücksichtigen
mehr Anträge bedeuten aber auch mehr
Arbeit für die Kommunen und deswegen
haben wir auch da vorgebeugt wir haben
die aber ganz hellgrenze eingeführt wir
haben den Bewilligungszeitraum
verlängert auf bis zu 24 Monaten gerade
für Menschen mit stabilem Einkommen wie
Rentner eben ist das eine wichtige
Erleichterung klar ist aber auch ich
würde jetzt nicht nur meckern wie sie
sondern ich würde klare Vorschläge
machen wenn sie planen einen
Wohngeldantrag zu stellen dann nutzen
Sie den
Wohngeldrechner vom Bauministerium den
gibt es der hat auch schon die aktuellen
Zahlen und auch das ist ein wichtiger
Beitrag wenn sie als Bürgerinnen und
Bürger das Gefühl haben Wohngeld das
könnte für mich was sein das zu nutzen
um zu verhindern dass es sehr viele
Anträge gibt die keine Aussicht auf
Erfolg haben ich glaube das ist ehrliche
Kommunikation
ein zweiter Baustein ist die Fähre
Aufteilung der co2-kosten zwischen
Mieterinnen und Vermietern mit den
Kohlenstoffdioxid Kosten
aufteilungsgesetz leisten wir einen
wichtigen Beitrag um einerseits
Klimaschutz und andererseits
mieterinnenschutz zusammenzubringen
unser Ziel ist dass die Gebäude
möglichst schnell saniert werden dann
brauchen wir auch keine Aufteilung der
co2-kosten mehr und auch keine
Diskussion über Höhe Energiepreise und
deswegen haben wir ein Stufenmodell
eingeführt das Vermieter stärker in die
Verantwortung gerade in den schlechtes
saniertesten Gebäuden haben wir
durchgesetzt das Vermieter in den
CO2-Preis zu 95% zahlen müssen
mieter:innen nur noch 5%, wir haben
außerdem erreicht dass alle bestehenden
Fernwärme Anschlüsse eingezogen werden
egal ob bthg oder ETF das ist gut fürs
Klima
und zum Schluss beide Gesetze das
Wohngeld Plus und das
co2-kostenaufteilungsgesetz haben eins
gemeinsam sie bringen einerseits
Sozialpolitik und Klimaschutz zusammen
das ist total wichtig dass wir das
Zusammenbringen der nur dann können wir
erfolgreich sein
und nun zum allerletzten Schluss Dank an
meine zahlreichen
mitberichterstatterinnen und an die gute
Zusammenarbeit mit den Ministerien mit
beiden Schritten gehen wir einen guten
Schritt voran Gesetz und gehen wir einen
Schritt voran darüber freue ich mich
vielen Dank
Anna Steinmüller hat hier der Gesetze
verteidigt und zum Schluss ja auch noch
mal das CO2
kostenaufteilungsgesetz angesprochen die
afd-fraktion fordert dieses abzulehnen
für die Fraktion spricht nun Sebastian
Münzenmaier Wohnungsmarkt ist dramatisch
laut Statistischem Bundesamt konnten
schon im Jahr 2021 2,6 Millionen
Menschen ihre Wohnung nicht mehr
ausreichend heizen und jeder vierte
mieterhaushalt ist momentan
armutsgefährdet was tun Sie also dagegen
zum ersten Januar wollen sie es Wohngeld
erhöhen und dafür sorgen dass in Zukunft
bis zu 2 Millionen Haushalte diese
Transferleistung beziehen können in der
momentanen Situation ist diese Hilfe
leider bitter notwendig dabei darf man
aber bitte nicht vergessen es war ihre
Energiepolitik die diese Menschen in die
Armut getrieben hat und jetzt werfen sie
Ihnen einige Almosen hin sie sind der
Brandstifter der sich dafür feiert dass
er im Anschluss die Feuerwehr gerufen
hat meine Damen und Herren
aufgrund der von ihnen verursachten
Notlage und im Interesse der betroffenen
Bürger bleibt uns heute aber keine
andere Wahl als dieses Gesetz trotz
enormer Menge Kollegin von der CDU hat
es gerade ausgeführt mitzutragen aber
ist es eigentlich nicht völlig verrückt
zu glauben dass man durch die Erhöhungen
Ausweitung des wohngelds die
grundlegenden Probleme auf dem
Wohnungsmarkt löst anstatt die Ursachen
der Misere anzupacken dr sie nämlich den
ganzen Tag nur ein Symptomen rum und
hoffen dann dass sich das Wahlvolk durch
Geldgeschenke blenden lässt warum
sprechen sie denn ein Problem nicht
offen an es gibt in Deutschland zu
wenige Wohnungen und Sie werden es nicht
schaffen in den kommenden Jahren diese
Zahl signifikant zu erhöhen das gibt
selbst die bauministerin ja ganz offen
zu gleichzeitig hatten wir im ersten
Halbjahr 2022
eine netto-zuwanderung von einer
Millionen Menschen
eine Million Menschen das sind mehr
Einwohner als Mainz Erfurt Saarbrücken
Wiesbaden und Schwerin zusammen das ist
kein Märchen nette Dame das ist die
Realität dass Sie nicht unsere Daten
dass das Statistische Bundesamt sie
holen also in sechs Monaten mehr
Ausländer in dieses Land als in fünf
Landeshauptstädten in diesem Land wohnen
und wundern sich dann dass der Wohnraum
knapp wird meine Damen und Herren lassen
Sie mich Ihnen einen Tipp geben wenn sie
es nicht schaffen auf der Angebotszeit
der mehr Wohnungen zu bauen dann müssen
Sie dafür sorgen dass die Nachfrageseite
bedient wird dass die Nachfrage also
zurückgeht meine Damen und Herren also
muss priorisiert werden liebe Frau esken
es muss priorisiert werden und wenn wir
priorisieren ist es ganz klar
einheimische zuerst meine Damen und
Herren wir brauchen mehr Wohnungen für
unsere eigenen Leute und deshalb eine
rückführungsoffensive abschieben schafft
Wohnraum spart Geld und sorgt für
Sicherheit auf unseren Straßen das eine
goldrandlösung für Entlastung in diesem
Bereich können Sie auf bestimmt meiner
Fraktion gerne zählen aber auch ihre
zweite entlastungsmaßnahme entpuppt sich
als Mogelpackung sie wollen ja mit dem
vorliegenden Gesetz die CO2 Kosten in
Zukunft zwischen Mieter und Vermieter
aufteilen und verkaufen das dann als
Entlastung der Mieter aber merken Sie
eigentlich wie ihre das ist auf der
einen Seite führen Sie eine CO2-Steuer
ein belasten die Menschen massiv mehr
und stellen sich dann und sagen ja und
jetzt entlasten wir jetzt verteilen wir
die Kosten und geben den Vermieter noch
mehr dazu das ist keine Lösung das ist
ein Hütchenspieler Trick und der wird
völlig in die Hose gehen meine Damen und
Herren mehr als 60 Prozent mehr als 60
Prozent der Vermieter in Deutschland
sind klein Vermieter die sich vielleicht
für die Altersvorsorge eine kleine
Wohnung erspart haben und die jetzt
vermieten die werden dadurch auch nicht
reich es gibt sogar knapp zehn Prozent
der privaten Vermieter die laut IWD
drauflegen jeden Monat und diese
Menschen wollen sie jetzt zusätzlich
belasten ich kann Ihnen sagen welche
Folgen das haben wir es wird in Zukunft
viele Menschen geben die sagen naja gut
in meinem kleinen Häuschen habe ich eine
Einliegerwohnung dann vermiete ich die
eben nicht mehr weil mir der
Bürokratieaufwand und die Zusatzkosten
einfach über den Kopf wachsen statt
Wohnraum zu schaffen sorgen sie mit
ihren grandiosen Ideen sogar für das
Gegenteil meine Damen und Herren die
CO2-Steuer muss nicht aufgeteilt sondern
abgeschafft werden fassen wir also
nochmal kurz zusammen sie bauen zu
wenige Wohnungen sie importieren
Millionen von Ausländern und dank ihrer
Energiepolitik werden immer mehr
Menschen in Deutschland Arm und abhängig
von staatlichen Leistungen wenn sie so
weitermachen werden in Zukunft statt 2
Millionen bei 20 Millionen Menschen
Wohngeld benötigen und was machen Sie
denn eigentlich dann wer soll denn diese
ganze Chose noch bezahlen stoppen Sie
also diesen irrwerk und ihr weg und
stellen Sie unsere deutschen Bürger
endlich wieder in den Mittelpunkt der
Politik Deutschland hat Eigenbedarf ich
danke Ihnen für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Sebastian Münzen Maja
kritisiert hier noch einmal das ist zu
wenig Wohnungen gibt
im westlobby noch die namentliche
Abstimmung läuft ich hatte vorhin gesagt
14 Uhr 15 werden die ungeschlossen mich
erreicht die Nachricht dass sowohl der
Haushaltsausschuss als auch der
Ältestenrat noch nicht vollständig
Gelegenheit hatte sich auf den Weg zu
machen ich werde mich also entsprechend
unterrichten lassen wann die Mitglieder
dieser beiden Gremien auch den die
Abstimmung erreicht haben gleichzeitig
bitte ich aber diejenigen die hier
anwesend sind und noch nicht Gelegenheit
hatten abzustimmen das schon einmal zu
erledigen
wir fahren in dir das ist noch mal zur
zum
inflationsausgleichsgesetzes die
namentliche Abstimmung hier geht's jetzt
aber weiter mit Daniel Fürstin Sprecher
für Bau und Wohnungspolitik der
FDP-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin werde Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ich bin jetzt seit fünf Jahren hier im
Parlament mit der AFD und ich muss jetzt
einmal sagen es ist jedes Jahr deutlich
in jeder Rede deutlich wie völlig egal
ihn sowohl die Wirtschaft als auch die
deutsche Gesellschaft ist landauf Land
abklagt jedes Unternehmen um
Fachkräftemangel und sie behaupten wir
brauchen keine Zuwanderung Deutschland
ist ein Einwanderungsland und auch das
wäre dieser Legislaturperiode klar
machen wir brauchen die Kräfte die zu
uns kommen und als viertgrößte
Volkswirtschaft der Welt als eine
wohlhabende Nation haben wir auch die
Verantwortung den Kriegsflüchtlingen zu
helfen wir haben eine Verantwortung des
schwächsten zu helfen und die die hier
nicht bleiben dürfen kein aufwärtel
haben die müssen gehen das ist die
Wahrheit und was sie da erzählen ist
einfach nur Polemik was aber auffällt in
ihrer Rede was auffällt in ihrer Rede
sie haben das gleiche brutale
vermieterbild wie die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der linke die AFD und die
Linke haben das gleiche vermieterbild
sie stellen sich hier hin und sagen Oma
Erna ist so eiskalt dass Ihre Wohnung
nicht mehr vermietet weil vielleicht 50
Euro CO2-Preis im Jahr zahlen drin das
sagen sie stellen sie sich hierher und
dieses dieses vermieterbild das ist eine
Beleidigung für die guten ehrlichen
kleinen Vermieter in Deutschland das
gilt für die AFD genauso wie für die
Linke so jetzt habe ich die ersten eine
Minute 20 dafür gebraucht für die drei
Themen die wir jetzt hier debattieren
ganz kurz ein Satz für zu den linken
Anträgen ich also ich finde die Hybris
ja wirklich beeindruckend wir brauchen
nur zum Fenster rausschauen und sehen
die völlig gescheiterte wohnen und
Mieten Politik der Linken in Berlin und
sie stellen sich hier hin und sagen das
was in Berlin ich glaube sollen wir hier
im Bundestag machen das ist ein eine
absurde Hybris die hinten und vorne
nicht funktionieren wird
was aber funktionieren wird im Gegensatz
zur Politik der Linken in Berlin was
funktionieren wird ist tatsächlich die
größte wohngeldreform die in Deutschland
gab und diese wohngeldreform ist
notwendig geworden weil sie gemacht
werden musste wir müssen den Menschen
unterstützen müssen den Mieterinnen und
Mietern die nicht mehr können den müssen
wir helfen völlig ohne Frage es gerade
jetzt in der Situation haben wir ein
Problem dass das auch die untere
Mittelschicht nicht mehr kann und das
werden das Wohngeld ausweiten ist
richtig dass wir eine
heizkostenkomponente mit reingebaut
haben ist richtig und dass wir eine
klimakomponente mit reinbauen auch da
bin ich allerdings tatsächlich bei der
Union die klima-komponente ist noch
nicht der Weisheit letzter Schluss
deswegen haben wir mit Grünen und SPD
auch formuliert dass wir die
klimakomponente so lange sobald wir das
Versäumnis der nicht rechtssicheren
Energieausweise gelöst haben die
klimakomponente tatsächlich Anknüpfen an
die
Energiezustand des Gebäudes das wir
werden es weiterentwickeln wir müssen
das ja sowieso anpassen weil auch
tatsächlich die die
Kategorie nie Zuordnungen die ist ja in
der Mache es ist eine wissenschaftliches
Prinzip das wird übernommen das werden
wir anpassen die wohngeldreform ist
wichtig sie ist richtig wir hören
natürlich auch die Aussagen der Kommunen
wir hören natürlich auch das wird
schwierig das schaffen wir nicht aber im
Gegensatz zur Union sagen wir wir machen
es trotzdem mal die Menschen die Hilfe
brauchen wir machen es trotzdem weil die
Menschen die Hilfe brauchen nur weil es
schwer ist die wohngeldreform nicht zu
machen das ist mit der Ampel nicht zu
machen wir zahlen die Hilfe die gezahlt
werden muss deswegen haben wir auch
deutliche Vereinfachungen in der
Bürokratie im Wohngeld vorgenommen wir
werden es auch sehr bald wieder
evaluieren des Wohngeldgesetz es Ziel
ist natürlich schon dass es ankommt bei
den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern die es
brauchen aber Einsatz bitte zu den
Kommunen weil es war auch Thema der
Anhörung ich muss das hier jetzt auch
mal Cora Publikum in der Öffentlichkeit
sagen seit drei Jahren glaube ich seit
drei oder vier Jahren gibt in
Schleswig-Holstein ein digitalen
bürgergeldantrag der die Spitzenverbände
die kommunalen Spitzenverbände sagen
dieser bürgergeldantrag der ist gut der
digitale aber er ist nicht Realität in
Deutschland warum wieder nicht
übernommen also auch die Kommunen auch
die Länder haben bitte die Verantwortung
ihre Verwaltung zu optimieren und vor
allem zu digitalisieren damit schneller
geht und zielgerichteter ankommt
ein ein wichtiger ein wichtiger Punkt
was habe ich gesagt vielen Dank Frau
eskimi meinte natürlich das Wohngeld
nicht das Bürgergeld ja ich war vorhin
bei der bürgergelddebatte und da habe
mich so über die Union aufgeregt
deswegen geht es mal wenn ich da rein
Schau denke ich als Bürgergeld aber
vielen Dank für die für den Hinweis
jetzt bleibt mir nicht mehr viel Zeit
für die co2-aufteilung mir ist aber ein
Punkt wichtig zu sagen bei der
co2-preisaufteilung
es ist da geht es nicht in erster Linie
um die Entlastung der Mieterinnen und
Mieter wie es gehen dargestellt wird es
geht darum dass wir in der Bepreisung
des CO2 die absolut richtig ist da
stehen wir frei Demokraten dazu jeder
wird sich für jedes Kilogramm
co2-rechtfertigen müssen dass wir bei
der Bepreisung von CO2 eine Aufteilung
hinkriegen die sowohl die die Eigentümer
als auch die Nutzer Anreiz Energie zu
sparen darum geht es bei der CO2 bereits
Aufteilung und das ist auch gelungen und
dass wir den Verbrauch heranziehen das
ist ja nicht ganz verkehrt weil wenn der
Herr Lucia gleich wieder sagen wird wir
brauchen eine Gebäude Energieausweis
auch der Gebäude Energieausweis ist
teilweise ein Verbrauchsausweis und doch
im Ausschuss gerne also ich weiß ich
weiß ich komme zum Ende ich hätte gern
noch drei Minuten mehr weil die Themen
wirklich sehr sehr wichtig ist wir
entlasten beim Wohngeld wir schaffen
Anreize bei der co2-preisaufteilung AFD
und Linke sind wieder mal völlig daneben
vielen Dank
Daniel erfüllt war das hat hier selber
wie er gesagt hat erst einmal ein
bisschen Zeit damit verbracht auf seinen
Vorredner zu antworten das ist ja immer
eine schöne wenn die Abgeordneten dazu
auch in der Lage sind in der Debatte und
hier nicht nur ablesen Karin sprechen
für mietenbau und Wohnungspolitik der
Linksfraktion spricht als nächstes
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
es ist gut dass der Heizkostenzuschuss
endlich kommt dass eine das ist eine
klimakomponente geben wird und dass die
Anspruchsberechtigten ausgeweitet werden
das sind richtige Schritte die wir als
LINKE immer gefordert haben und ich bin
froh dass sie endlich kommen
doch kommen wir nun zu den Problemen
erstens das Wohngeld muss so berechnet
sein dass es zum Leben reicht 30 Prozent
des Einkommens sollen eigentlich maximal
für die warme Miete ausgegeben werden
die Koalition kalkuliert allerdings mit
40 Prozent und da sind die Stromkosten
noch nicht drin das heißt die
finanzielle Überlastung von Haushalten
wird einkalkuliert das darf nicht sein
zweitens die Kommunen stehen für eine
Antragsflut die sie personell nicht
stemmen können wir haben vorgeschlagen
die alten Anträge vorläufig um ein Jahr
zu verlängern damit die neuen Anträge
bewilligt werden können doch leider
wurde dieser Vorschlag nicht
aufgegriffen und drittens das
komplizierte mietstufensystem das war
schon immer ungerecht das wissen alle
Fachleute
jetzt wollen sie zusätzlich auch noch
188 Gemeinden herabstufen in diesen
Gemeinden können dann im schlimmsten
Falle die Zuschüsse für die Kaltmieten
sogar sinken wie soll ich das in meinem
Wahlkreis erzählen wo vier Städte davon
betroffen sind oder in Chemnitz oder in
Rostock in Rostock sind die
Angebotsmieten im letzten Jahr um 12%
gestiegen im Ergebnis ihrer Reform kann
es passieren dass eine Familie im
Extremfall 100 Euro weniger Zuschüsse
für die Kaltmiete bekommt das ist doch
völlig absurd
der deutsche Metatag die Gewerkschaften
der Deutschen Städtetag und der
Bundesrat kritisierendes wir haben einen
Änderungsantrag vorgelegt der darauf
verzichtet auf diese Ungesagte
Herabstufung stimmen Sie unserem Antrag
zu dann können wir auch Ihrem Gesetz
zustimmen ansonsten natürlich nicht denn
dann bleibt es einfach an rumgemorkse
mit schweren Fehlern
und drittens das Grundproblem beim
Wohngeld ist doch dass man aufpassen
muss dass es keine staatliche Subvention
des mietenwahnsinns ist über den sich am
Ende des Tages die Aktionäre von
wohnovia freuen und deswegen muss eine
wohngeldreform Hand in Hand gehen mit
einem mietenstopp und genau das
beantragen wir als LINKE heute
und wir beantragen einen besseren
Kündigungsschutz den hat auch die
bauministerin versprochen aber er ist
noch nicht da wir beantragen ein Verbot
von Zwangsräumungen und von
indexmietverträgen das mag ihn ja alles
zu weit gehen aber von der Ampel ist
doch nichts gekommen im Mietrecht das
ist die Wahrheit
und schließlich der CO2-Preis sie machen
es nur ein bisschen gerechter aber sie
wissen ganz genau dass es immer noch
eine überproportionale Belastung der
Mieterinnen und Mieter bedeutet und ganz
im Ernst eine CO2 Bepreisung ist
angesichts dieser Energiepreis Explosion
doch wirklich aus der Zeit gefallen wir
können die Kosten nicht noch per Gesetz
nach oben treiben das beste wäre wenn
Preisung der Heizkosten komplett
zurückgenommen wurde
Karin allein von der Linksfraktion
nannte hier die Gesetzentwürfe ein
rumgemuchtes mit schweren Fehlern
wir können also davon ausgehen dass die
Linksfraktion eher verhalten ist zu
diesem Wohngeld plus Gesetzentwurf sehr
geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit dem Gesetz
zur Aufteilung der co2-kosten sorgen wir
für mehr Gerechtigkeit das Mieterinnen
und Mieter alleine die Zusatzkosten für
den CO2-Preis auf Öl und Gas zahlen wird
sich nun ändern und ich kann nur sagen
endlich dadurch werden Millionen von
Menschen gezielt entlastet in den
vergangenen Wochen haben wir den
Gesetzesentwurf intensiv beraten und in
einigen Stellen auch noch mal
nachgebessert und zwar ganz wichtig dass
die Mieterinnen und Mieter in
energetisch schlechtesten Gebäuden noch
weniger zahlen müssen als ursprünglich
geplant nämlich jetzt nur noch 5% der
co2-kosten es wird außerdem ein
Online-Tool geben mit dem die Anteile
der co2-kosten ganz einfach
unbürokratisch und fehlerfrei berechnet
werden können wir haben also einen guten
Kompromiss gefunden und deshalb möchte
ich meine Redezeit jetzt auch nutzen und
noch einmal ganz grundsätzlich die
Notwendigkeit des co2-preises für einige
Teile des Hauses auch anscheinend
aufzuzeigen denn es gibt ja einige die
den CO2-Preis am liebsten abschaffen
würden darunter natürlich die
wissenschaftsleugner der AFD die bis
heute noch nicht verstanden haben wie
CO2-Ausstoß und Klimawandel denn
eigentlich Zusammenhängen auch für sie
nochmal wenn wir so weitermachen mit dem
Fuß auf dem Gaspedal auf dem Highway in
die Klima Hölle wie es Antonio guteresch
bei der UN Klimakonferenz formuliert hat
werden beispielsweise extreme
Flutkatastrophen keine schlimmen
jahrhundert Ereignisse mehr bleiben
sondern häufiger vorkommen
als Ampel machen wir also das einzig
logische wir bringen Maßnahmen auf den
Weg klimaschädliche Emissionen zu
verringern deswegen der CO2-Preis auch
im Gebäude Sektor aber eben mit einer
fairen Aufteilung und den zwei
Komponenten wie Kollege Fürst ist auch
schon erwähnt hat Anreiz zu
energetischen Sanierung und zu
energiesparendem Fall
denen die jetzt gegen den CO2-Preis
wettern und vorgeben dabei auf der Seite
der kleinen Leute zu stehen kann ich nur
sagen sie haben es nicht verstanden mit
dem CO2-Preis bitten wir besonders
diejenigen zur Kasse die das Klima am
meisten schädigen das sind die die viel
und zwar so richtig viel Geld auf dem
Konto haben genau das sagt auch die
Statistik die reichsten zehn Prozent
verursachen die Hälfte der Treibhausgase
das heißt zwar kann und sollte auch
jeder etwas tun um CO2 einzusparen aber
der große Klimasünder ist eben nicht der
Arbeiter nach einem langen Tag bei
eisigen Temperaturen daheim noch einmal
die halte Heizung auftreten das ist auch
nicht die Krankenschwester die sich nach
der nächsten Überstunde zu Hause noch
unter die warme Decke kuschelt
Dusche stellt klar wäre es für das Klima
besser wenn Sie eine moderne
klimafreundliche Heizung hätten und
Solarpanels zu warm Wasser erzogen aber
oftmals steht das außer Frage weil sie
als bietende entweder keinen Einfluss
darauf haben oder als Eigentümer nicht
genügend Geld für diese Investition
aufbringen können ich habe ihn also voll
davon dass die Verantwortung für die
Zukunft unseres Planeten auf den
einzelnen abgeladen wird wir müssen uns
endlich auf die großen Klimasünder
fokussieren und wir müssen die Menschen
noch stärker unterstützen die eben nur
gering finanziellen Spielraum haben
deswegen haben wir uns im
Koalitionsvertrag auch auf ein
Klimagerät geeinigt durch das die
Einnahmen aus dem CO2-Preis wieder an
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger zurückfließen
werden die reichsten Klimasünder machen
dabei Minusgeschäft und es profitieren
diejenigen die wenig CO2-Emissionen
verursachen und das sind oft die
Menschen die wenig Geld haben das denn
nicht sozial gerecht dankeschön
Martin diedenhoven ist hier noch mal
darauf eingegangen mit welchen Maßnahmen
hier gerecht verteilt werden soll in der
Vergangenheit wurde er auf kritisiert
dass diese
entlastungs-pakete wie eine Gießkanne
verteilt wurden sprich auch diejenigen
profitiert haben die eigentlich nicht so
sehr unter den höheren Preisen und unter
der Inflation leiden
Bundestags viel zu Präsidentin Petra Pau
erinnert hier noch einmal an die
Abstimmung zum
inflationsausgleichsgesetzes in der
westlobby findet dass er statt
und nun geht es aber weiter mit dem
nächsten Redner Ulrich lange
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
der Unionsfraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich bin am Rednerpult
angekommen und freue mich jetzt auf auf
eine entsprechende Debatte nachdem man
uns ja vorhin gesagt hätte wir hätten
keine Vorschläge gemacht liebe Kollegin
der Grünen zwei Vorschläge zwei
Entschließungsanträge zu jedem Gesetz
lesen Sie es nach von uns bekommen Sie
immer gute Ideen zu einem Gesetz denn
wir sind eine konstruktive
Opposition
es befreitet ja niemand dass wir beim
Wohngeld etwas machen müssen nur liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sie sind zu
spät sie sind zu bürokratisch sie setzen
es schlecht um und Sie können die
Kommunen nicht außen vor lassen so wie
es die Kollegin Anne Königinnen vorhin
schon gesagt hat gegen die Kommunen
gegen die die vor Ort das umsetzen
müssen lassen sich auch hier in Berlin
keine Gesetze machen verankern Sie sich
endlich auf der unteren Ebene liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die CO2 Bepreisung ist ja jetzt
sozusagen zum Anhängsel dieser Debatte
geworden das ist mir natürlich auch klar
warum
denn da möchte der ein oder andere nicht
daran erinnert werden an das was er mal
erzählt hat und dem was er jetzt gerade
hier zustimmen muss oder will das ist
auch so ein bisschen typischer ampelstil
erst streiten dann herumwerkeln und dann
viel zu spät kommen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der Grund Webfehler dieses
Gesetzes bleibt bestehen der
energetische Zustand des Gebäudes wird
nicht entsprechend eingestellt sie hängt
sie hängen die Kosten davon ab wie das
individuelle Heizverhalten ist und das
kann nicht richtig sein liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
zehn Stufen bürokratisch und umständlich
das ist doch nicht FDP liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen da haben sie doch anderes
versprochen die Qualität des Gebäudes
nicht berücksichtigt da haben sie doch
anderes versprochen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen genau daran haben sie aber
nichts geändert auch hier kann ich noch
mal sagen eine echte Opposition mit
echten Vorschlägen für einfache Stufen
abhängig vom Gebäudezustand gerecht für
Mieter und Vermieter das ist ein Modell
dass wir Ihnen empfehlen und dass wir
Ihnen mit unserem Antrag heute zur
Abstimmung anbieten diese beiden Gesetze
die können wir nicht mittragen danke
schön
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Zeit
für die namentliche Abstimmung zum
inflationsausgleichgesetz ist abgelaufen
ist noch ein Mitglied des Hauses
anwesend welches seine Stimme nicht
abgeben konnte
das ist nicht der Fall ich schließe die
Abstimmung und bitte die
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer mit
der Auszählung zu Beginn das Ergebnis
der Abstimmung wird Ihnen später bekannt
gegeben
wir fahren fort in der Debatte zum
Wohngeld plus Gesetz und anderen
Vorlagen das Wort hat die Kollegin
Christina Johanna Schröder für die
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die bringen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen sehr geehrte
Gästinnen heute ist ein guter Tag denn
viele BürgerInnen bei uns im Land sind
verunsichert und wir geben als Parlament
die notwendige Sicherheit ein Puzzleteil
ist das heute beschlossene Bürgergeld es
ist die Erhöhung des Kindergelds auf 250
Euro ihr Kind das ist der Heizkosten
zwar Zuschuss zwei den wir schon in der
Vergangenheit beschlossen haben und es
ist jetzt diese große Novelle des
Wohngeldes mehr als zwei Millionen
Haushalte werden in Zukunft profitieren
und darunter sind ganz besonders viele
Alleinerziehende oder rentner:innen
es braucht noch mehr es kommt noch mehr
Sicherheit wollen wir geben um sozial
der Härten abzusenken wie Gas und
strompreisbremse so Frau König sie haben
vorn von Hölle gesprochen ich spreche
sie übrigens an
und warum warum haben wir eine Inflation
warum gehen die Energiepreise durch die
Decke das hat wohl mit einem
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine zu tun und
ich finde das Wort Hölle zu beschreiben
dafür dass Kommunen tatsächlich in der
Tat belastet werden durch ein Gesetz ist
glaube ich in dem Gesamtkontext absolut
unangemessen
und es ist wahr und das ist wahr wir
haben uns sicherlich als Grünen auch ein
paar Vereinfachungen mehr gewünscht aber
was wäre die Alternative gewesen das
Wohngeld nicht anzupassen keine Erhöhung
keine Entlastung für so viele Haushalte
und wir haben ja Evaluation vereinbart
einmal eben beim Energiebedarfsausweis
aber auch bei der klimakomponente und
warum konnten wir in
Energiebedarfsausweis nicht nehmen eben
weil der nicht rechtssicher war also
bitte erstmal auf die eigene nicht
getane Arbeit der letzten 16 Jahre
gucken und dann dann nicht mit Hölle
angesetzten rum kritisieren
so es wurde auch schon viel zum
co2-kostenaufteilungsgesetz gesagt aber
auch das beraten wir hier und auch das
ist eine gute Sache denn es entlastet
eben jene mieter:innen die in besonders
schlecht sanierten Wohnungen wohnen und
das sind eben jene die oft wenig Geld
haben und das sind eben jene die auch
wenig Chancen auf den angespannten
mietmärkten haben deswegen ist das eine
gute Sache und es ist zugegebenerweise
auch ein kleiner Anreiz für
vermieter:innen zu sanieren auch eine
gute Sache der Entlastung und ein
bisschen Klimagerechtigkeit in
Deutschland herzustellen
[Applaus]
ein Problem haben wir nicht gelöst denn
man muss einfach zugeben die hohen
Mieten die subventionieren wir schon ein
wenig durch das Wohngeld aber auch jetzt
durch Hartz IV oder auch durch das
zukünftige Bürgergeld wir stellen uns
ein auf ein Mietmarkt der nach wie vor
überteuert ist und während bei
Immobilien und Grundstücke langsam die
Preise anfangen zu sinken gehen die
Mieten weiter in vielen Regionen
Deutschlands einfach durch die Decke und
deswegen braucht es in Ballungsgebieten
neue Wohnung aber eben nicht nur Neubau
sondern auch Belegungsrechte eben um
eine soziale Mischung zu gewährleisten
wir brauchen die Umnutzung von Büro und
Gewerbegebiete Aufstockung
Lückenbebauung und wir brauchen ein
schärferes Mietrecht und natürlich die
Wiedereinführung der
wohngemeinnützigkeit
ohne diesen Dreiklang aus Baurecht
Mietrecht und Angebotserweiterung aber
ganz besonders durch nicht
gewinnorientierte Akteure werden die
Mieten nicht dauerhaft sinken
liebe Kollegen der linke ein Wort noch
zu ihrer Kritik das sind einigen
Kommunen tatsächlich der
bezieherinnenkreis sinkt das lag an der
Datenbasis und der BBSR macht gerade
eine Studie um solide die Einstufung von
Städten auf eine wissenschaftliche
basierte und gerechte Basis zu stellen
was wäre da die Alternative gewesen dass
wir politisch am grünen Tisch
entscheiden wo welche
statt eingestuft wird ich weiß wir haben
Zuschriften von Kommunen bekommen aber
ich glaube eine wissenschaftlich
fundierte Basis des BBSR das ist eine
gute Entscheidungsgrundlage für die
zukünftige Politik vielen Dank
wir kommen zum vorletzten Redner bevor
hier einige Abstimmungen anstehen
mehrere Redner haben es ja auch schon
angekündigt dass sie Anträge hier
eingereicht haben jetzt spricht aber
erst einmal der Sprecher für Wohnstadt
Entwicklung Bauwesen und Kommunen der
Unionsfraktion Jan Marco Luczak
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren wir haben gerade gehört
dass es hier bei dieser Reform um einen
Meilenstein handeln soll um eine
jahrhunderte Reform und ich werfe der
Ministerin jetzt auch gar nicht vor dass
sie nicht da ist wir haben gehört sie
ist im Haushalt das ist in Ordnung was
ich ihr aber vorwerfe und was ich den
gesamten Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
der Ampel wenn das eine solche
Jahrhundertreform sein sollte dann
hätten sie verdammt noch mal mehr
Sorgfalt aufwenden müssen dann hätten
sie schneller sein müssen das was Sie
uns hier vorlegen das ist bestenfalls
gut gemeint in der Sache ist es aber
richtig schlecht gemacht
es ist uns völlig klar in dieser
wirklich schwierigen Situation in der
sich die Menschen gerade befinden
natürlich müssen wir den Mietern helfen
und im übrigen auch den selbst Nutzern
die haben ja auch Anspruch auf von Geld
selbstverständlich müssen wir den helfen
aber das Problem an dem was sie uns hier
vorschlagen ist ja das wird den Menschen
nicht helfen das wird den Menschen nicht
helfen weil das handwerklich schlecht
gemacht ist und zu spät kommt wir werden
bittere Enttäuschungen durch dieses
Gesetz erleben wir wissen wenn Sie mit
den Kommunen reden die sind heute alle
schon personell total überlastet die
durchschnittliche Bearbeitungszeit für
einen Antrag auf Wohngeld beträgt heute
schon sechs Monate in einzelne Kommunen
sind es zwölf Monate
durch die Reform die wir jetzt in den
Angriff nehmen die wir als Union im Ziel
absolut Teilen noch mal die Menschen
muss geholfen werden durch diese Reform
wird aus dem momentanen 600.000 Menschen
die Wohngeld beziehen 2 Millionen also
eine Verdreifachung der Menschen und
jetzt können Sie sich und jetzt können
Haushalte jetzt können sie sich ja
vorstellen was mit den
Bearbeitungszeiten die heute noch mal
sechs Monate betragen geschieht wenn wir
jetzt sozusagen dreimal so viele
Menschen in das Wohngeld bringen und
natürlich werden sich diese
antragszeiten entsprechend verlängert
und das wird dann dazu führen dass die
Menschen im Januar wenn sie sagen
wunderbar jetzt haben wir diese Wohnwelt
geformt ich stelle den Antrag ich
brauche diese hilfe ich bin drauf
angewiesen sie stellen den Antrag und
dann passiert viele Monate überhaupt gar
nichts sie werden bitter enttäuscht
werden und das wird uns allen auf die
Füße fallen weil sie zu spät gehandelt
haben weil sie die Kommunen nicht
rechtzeitig in einbezogen haben mit
vereinfachungsvorschlägen das ist
einfach handwerklich schlecht was sie
hier gemacht haben meine Damen und
Herren
und das Schlimme dabei ist ja noch es
geht ja nicht nur um die Menschen die
jetzt neu wohngeldberechtigt
bürgerberechtigt werden sondern auch die
aktuell schon Wohngeld beziehen bei
denen ist es ja auch so bei denen muss
das ja auch alles neu berechtigt werden
das heißt im schlimmsten Falle kann es
jetzt passieren dass jemand jetzt der in
den vergangenen Monaten Wohngeld
bekommen hat der jetzt im Januar und im
Februar und im März und so weiter dann
aber keinen Wohngeld bekommt weil
nämlich die Kommunen nicht
hinterherkommen seinen aktuellen Antrag
zurzeit vorzubeziehen das heißt sie
verschlechtern für manche Menschen sogar
die Situation das kann doch nicht ihr
Ernst sein liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Ampel
und jetzt haben sie weil sie gefragt
haben was hätten wir da machen müssen
der Kollege lange hat darauf hingewiesen
wir hätten einen einfachen
übergangsmechanismus machen können das
haben auch die Kommunen vorgeschlagen wo
man gesagt hat zeitnah muss den Menschen
das Geld zu Teil werden wo man darauf
hätte abgestellt dass man die sehr
komplizierten Berechnung beim Einkommen
im Paragraph 14 ist wohngeldgesetzes wo
es über 30 Punkte gibt mit vielen
Unterpunkten was man dort alles angeben
muss was kein Mensch versteht von den
antragsberechtigen was in den Kommunen
eben zu diesen Schwierigkeiten führt das
hätte man radikal vereinfachen müssen
eine ganz einfache Einkommensprüfung und
dann wäre es auch gelungen den Menschen
das Geld rechtzeitig zu Teil werden
kommen aber das haben sie alles
abgelehnt sie haben auf die Experten in
der Anhörung nicht gehört und das müssen
sie sich wenn am Januar die Menschen da
stehen und kein Geld haben das müssen
sie sich ankreien lassen dass es ihr
Verschulden meine Damen und Herren
und jetzt will ich ganz am Schluss noch
zu der Frage der CO2 Kosten auch noch
etwas sagen da ist schon ihr vier gesagt
worden und auch hier haben wir einen
Vorschlag gemacht noch mal der CO2-Preis
als solche der ist richtig aber er ist
nur dann richtig wenn er am Ende auch
lenkungswirkungen erzeugt das was sie
jetzt vorschlagen indem sie abstellen
nicht auf den energetischen Zustand des
Gebäudes nicht ob ein Gebäude
modernisiert worden ist oder nicht das
führt am Ende dazu weil sie auf den
Brennstoffverbrauch auf das
Heizverhalten abstehen führt am Ende
dazu dass diejenigen die alles machen
was wir wollen nämlich sparsam mit
Heizenergie umgehen dass die am Ende
bestraft werden weil dann die Gebäude
besser einqualifiziert werden und die
Vermieter dann am Ende ein geringerer
Anteil sein das heißt die Mieterinnen
und Mieter die sparsam heizen werden am
Ende durch ihr Gesetz bestraft da können
wir unsere Zustimmung nicht erteilen das
ist absurd das hat keine Lenkungswirkung
aus klimapolitisch absolut
kontraproduktiv meine Damen und Herren
vielen Dank
ich komme zurück zum Zusatzpunkt 5 und
gebe ihnen das von den
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführern
ermittelte Ergebnis der namentlichen
Abstimmung bekannt
abgegebene stimmenkarten
691 mit ja haben 581 Kolleginnen und
Kollegen gestimmt mit Nein stimmten 35
und 75 Kolleginnen und Kollegen haben
sich enthalten der Gesetzentwurf ist
angenommen so und damit das
inflationsausgleichsgesetz was ja unter
anderem den Freibetrag erhöht ab
nächstem Jahr und damit kommen wir hier
aber wieder zur nächsten Rednerin
unserer letzten Sand da Martens für die
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
demokratischen Parteien Liebe
Mieterinnen und Mieter wir haben vor
zwei Wochen an genau dieser Stelle schon
mal drüber diskutiert wie wir den
Mieterinnen und Mietern in dieser
Krisenzeit der explodierenden
Betriebskosten gezielt helfen können und
einiges wird sich heute positiv für die
MieterInnen ändern weil wir gleich das
wollen wir jetzt plus beschließen wir
erhöhen das Wohngeld und erweitern es
auch auf Haushalte die diese
Unterstützung dringend benötigen aber
bislang nicht wohngeldberechtigt waren
allein damit werden wir bundesweit rund
2 Millionen Haushalte helfen dreimal so
vielen wie ich heute
ein kleiner Schritt für den
Finanzminister aber ein großer für alle
Betroffenen Mieterinnen und Mieter und
MieterInnen das ist in Deutschland die
übergroße Mehrheit liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das Gesetz allein bringt aber
noch niemandem auch nur ein einzigen
Euro mehr aufs Konto eine Volk ist die
wohngeldreform erst dann wenn auch die
Länder und Kommunen ihre politischen
finanziellen und verwaltungstechnischen
Aufgaben zügig und zeitnah gelöst
bekommen auch das müssen wir aus
Bundestagsabgeordnete vor Augen haben
wenn wir hier die notwendigen Gesetze
beschließen und spätestens dann wenn wir
wieder in unsere Wahlkreise zurückkehren
ist es auch unsere Aufgabe vor Ort zu
schauen ob die von uns erlassenen
Gesetze dort auch umgesetzt werden
können
liegt in Düsseldorf und ich möchte dass
das Wohngeld plus dass wir hier
beschließen auch den Düsseldorferinnen
zugute kommt zur Umsetzung der
wohngeldreform habe ich deshalb den
Düsseldorfer Oberbürgermeister konkret
befragt wohl wissend dass bereits jetzt
nur die Hälfte der Berechtigten aus
Unkenntnis oder Scham ihr Recht auf
Wohngeld in Anspruch nimmt und die
Antwort auf meine Fragen zeigen mir die
unterschiedlich die Kommunen und Länder
mit der Problematik umgehen und dass wir
unbedingt darauf achten müssen dass die
wohngeldreform nicht nur hier im
plenarsa verbleibt sondern tatsächlich
die Menschen im Land erreicht die sie so
dringend benötigen und auch in
Düsseldorf wird sich die Zahl der
wohngeldberechtigten Haushalte
voraussichtlich verdreifachen so die
Antwort aus dem Rathaus und auch die die
das Personal wird dort aufgestockt
etappt metappenweise in der nächsten ein
bis zwei Jahren und auch die
online-antragstellung muss erst noch
etabliert werden das ist fast schon
folgerichtig dass man auch keine
zusätzliche aufklärungs Arbeit machen
und Beratungen anbieten will aber das
darf uns nicht passieren dass die Reform
vor Ort wegen bundesweit fehlen da
Digitalisierung nicht umgesetzt werden
kann Oliver totgeschwiegen wird damit
weniger Haushalte davon erfahren und es
nicht oder noch mehr Anträge zu
bearbeiten gibt aber es gibt auch andere
Herangehensweisen und wir zum Beispiel
hier schon erwähnte Berlin gerade Berlin
ist in der mieterszene natürlich
bundesweit dafür bekannt dass sie mutig
vorangehen auch auf einem Mietrecht
Neuland betreten griechische Niederlagen
in Kauf nehmen weil sie eine soziale
mietenpolitik wohnen und sie bereiten
sich auf die Bewältigung einer
verdreifachten Zahl an wohngeldanträgen
vor Personal aus anderen Ämtern wird
mobilisiert soziale Beratungsstellen
aufgestockt weil man sich einfach gesagt
hat das Geld muss bei den Menschen
ankommen und solches anpacken von
Problemen würde ich mir von allen
Kommunen und Ländern wünschen das ist
wichtig aber nur eine von vielen
Maßnahmen mit dem wir das Leben in der
galoppierenden Inflation erreichen
wollen wir warten gespannt auf das noch
für dieses Jahr
versuchen der versprochenen
Gesetzentwurf zu Mietrecht wir müssen an
dieser Stelle auch das Mietrecht
demnächst besser machen können vielen
Dank
ich schließe die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Abstimmung über den von den
Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur
Erhöhung des Wohngeldes der Ausschuss
für Wohnen Stadtentwicklung Bauwesen und
Kommunen empfiehlt unter Buchstabe a
seiner Beschlussempfehlung auf
Drucksache
4.356 den Gesetzentwurf der Fraktionen
der SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
auf Drucksache
3.936 in der ausschussfassung anzunehmen
hierzu liegt ein Änderungsantrag der
Fraktion Die Linke auf Drucksache
4.365 vor und in diesem Änderungsantrag
gefordert die Linke unter anderem das
ist keine Herabstufung von Kommunen beim
Wohngeld geben darf Hintergrund ist ja
dass die mietenstufen neu festgelegte
werden das muss gemacht werden wenn es
eine Gesetzesänderung gibt und da möchte
eben die Linke nicht das ist dort zu
Kürzungen kommt aber dieser
Änderungsantrag wurde abgelehnt jedem
Gesetzentwurf der Fraktionen der SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP auf
Drucksache
3.936 in der ausschussfassung zustimmen
wollen um das Handzeichen wer stimmt
dagegen
Entschuldigung um das Handzeichen ich
war jetzt hier ein Schritt zu weit
ja die Zustimmung also hier noch mal
zurück
die koalitionsfraktion und die
afd-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen
die
cdu/csu-fraktion wer enthält sich die
Fraktion DIE LINKE der Gesetzentwurf ist
damit in zweiter Beratung angenommen
dritte Beratung und Schlussabstimmung
ich bitte diejenigen die den
Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben
danke wer stimmt dagegen
danke wer enthält sich
danke der Gesetzentwurf ist mit den
Stimmen der Koalitionsfraktionen und der
afd-fraktion gegen die Stimmen der
cdu/csu-fraktion bei Enthaltung der
Fraktion DIE LINKE angenommen
wir kommen zur Abstimmung über die
Entschließungsanträge
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion der
cdu/csu auf Drucksache
4.366 in diesem erfordert die
Unionsfraktion eine Übergangsphase bei
der wohngeldreform dass das Geld in
leichter ausgezahlt werden kann weil man
eben befürchtet dass es Probleme und
Verzögerungen bei der Umsetzung dieser
Reform gibt
niemand der Entschließungsantrag ist
abgelehnt
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion Die
Linke auf Drucksache
4367 wer stimmt für diesen
Entschließungsantrag
die Fraktion DIE LINKE wer stimmt
dagegen
die übrigen Fraktionen des Hauses wer
enthält sich niemand der
Entschließungsantrag ist abgelehnt wir
sind noch immer beim Tagesordnungspunkt
12 und setzen die Abstimmung zu der
Beschlussempfehlung des Ausschusses wir
wohnen Stadtentwicklung Bauwesen und
Kommunen auf der Drucksache
4.356 fort der Ausschuss empfiehlt unter
Buchstabe b seiner Beschlussempfehlung
den gleichlautenden Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung auf Drucksache
4.230 für erledigt zu erklären wer
stimmt für diese Beschlussempfehlung
danke bestimmt dagegen wer enthält sich
die Beschlussempfehlung ist einstimmig
angenommen
Zusatzpunkt 8a Abstimmung über den von
der Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurf zur Aufteilung der
kohlendioxidkosten der Ausschuss für
Wohnen Stadtentwicklung Bauwesen und
Kommunen empfiehlt unter Buchstabe aus
einer Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache
4.383 den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung auf Drucksache
3.172 in der ausschussfassung anzunehmen
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen
das sind die Koalitionsfraktionen wer
stimmt dagegen
die cdu/csu-fraktion und die
afd-fraktion wer enthält sich die
Fraktion DIE LINKE der Gesetzentwurf ist
damit in zweiter Beratung angenommen
dritte Beratung und Schlussabstimmung
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben
danke wer stimmt dagegen
danke er enthält sich
danke der Gesetzentwurf ist mit den
Stimmen der koalitionsfraktion gegen die
Stimmen der cdu/csu-fraktion und der
afd-fraktion bei Enthaltung der Fraktion
DIE LINKE angenommen
wir kommen zur Abstimmung über die
Entschließungsanträge gibt es zwei
Entschließungsanträge ein von der
Unionsfraktion ein von der afd-fraktion
erst einmal wird jetzt der
Entschließungsantrag der Union
abgestimmt unter anderem fordert die
Union das Vermieter von Gebäuden die
einen sehr hohen energetischen Standard
aufweisen von den co2-kosten ganz
freigestellt werden
jemand der Entschließungsantrag ist
abgelehnt und damit kommen wir jetzt zum
Entschließungsantrag der afd-fraktion in
diesem fordert die Fraktion unter
anderem die Umsatzsteuer für Energie
also stromgas Heizöl Fernwärme und Kohle
befristet auf null Prozent zu senken
der Entschließungsantrag ist mit den
Stimmen der
Koalition die Linke gegen die Stimmen
der afd-fraktion abgedeckt
Zusatzpunkt 8 b wir setzen die
Abstimmung zu der Beschlussempfehlung
des Ausschusses für Wohnen
Stadtentwicklung Bauwesen und Kommunen
auf Drucksache
4.383 fort der Ausschuss empfiehlt unter
Buchstabe b seiner Beschlussempfehlung
die Ablehnung des Antrags der Fraktionen
die Linke auf Drucksache
1.329 mit dem Titel
CO2-Preis nicht den Mieterinnen und
Mietern aufbürgen wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung
danke wer stimmt dagegen
danke wer enthält sich die
Beschlussempfehlung ist mit den Stimmen
der koalitionsfraktion der
cdu/csu-fraktion der afd-fraktion gegen
die Stimmen der Fraktion DIE LINKE
angenommen
Zusatzpunkt 9
Beschlussempfehlung des
Rechtsausschusses auf Drucksache
4.370 der Ausschuss empfiehlt unter
Buchstabe a seiner Beschlussempfehlung
die Ablehnung des Antrags der Fraktion
Die Linke auf Drucksache
2685 mit dem Titel
bundesweiter mietenstopp angesichts
hoher Inflationsraten wer stimmt für
diese Beschlussempfehlung
danke wer stimmt dagegen
danke wer enthält sich die
Beschlussempfehlung ist mit den Stimmen
der Koalitionsfraktionen der
cdu/csu-fraktion der afd-fraktion gegen
die Stimmen der Fraktionen die Linke
angenommen und der Buchstabe b empfiehlt
der Ausschuss die Ablehnung des Antrags
der Fraktion Die Linke auf Drucksache
2687 mit dem Titel
mietanpassungen von indexmieten
untersagen wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung
danke wer stimmt dagegen danke wer
enthält sich die Beschlussempfehlung ist
mit den Stimmen der Koalitionsfraktionen
der cdu/csu-fraktion und der
afd-fraktion gegen die Stimmen der
Fraktion DIE LINKE angenommen
schließlich empfiehlt der Ausschuss
unter Buchstabe c seiner
Beschlussempfehlung die Ablehnung des
Antrags der Fraktion Die Linke auf
Drucksache
4.054 mit dem Titel keine Kündigungen
Mieterinnen und Mieter in der
energiepreiskrise besser schützen wer
stimmt für diese Beschlussempfehlung
danke wer stimmt dagegen danke wer
enthält sich die Beschlussempfehlung des
mit den Stimmen der Koalitionsfraktionen
der cdu/csu-fraktion und er Fraktion der
afd-fraktion gegen die Stimmen der
Fraktion DIE LINKE angenommen
ich und damit haben wir diesen kleinen
Abstimmung zu Marathon zu Wohngeld
Fragen heute hier beendet das Wohngeld
plus Gesetz kommt